تحديده سعر النفط الروسيه اتفاق تواصلت
اليه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي 27 ومجموعه
السبع واستراليا رفقه رفض روسي وعدم رضا
اوكرانيا الاتفاق نص على حد اقصى لسعر
الخام الروسيه يبلغ 60 دولارا للبرميل
الواحد وابرم الاتفاق بعد ان كان معلقا من
قبل بولندا التي اعطاك الضوء الاخضر لهذه
الخطه وينتظر بدء تطبيقه غدا امر رئيس
الاوكراني
يعجبه الرقم المتفق عليه واعتبر انه لا
يعكس جديه تقدم الهدف المرجو لاضعف موسكو
في المقابله الموقف الروسي بدا واضحا منذ
اللحظه الاولى لقرار تحديد سقف لسعر نفطها
فالمتحدث باسم الكربلائي
بلاده امام تحديد سقف لسعر النقد الروسي
وان موسكو لن تزود الدول التي ستطبق هذا
القرار الاوروبي بدوره اكد نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي
ان روسيا لن تتعامل بموجب سقف اسعار النفط
فاذا اضطرت الى حظ الانتاج سفير روسيا لدى
المنظمات الدوليه في الجنه الاوليانو قال
بالفم الملان انه اعتبارا من العام الجاري
ستعيش اوروبا بدون النفط الروسيه